- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large brain. Long the
master of fire, tools, and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Mark] I would like to thank the
organizers. This is great opportunity to
come and listen to all these talks and
present some as well. So I would like to
start...so genes are really central and
they're central for a couple of reasons.
Well we can use lots of sources of
evidence to identify which are the genes
that are important in any process. Here,
we're talking about skin pigmentation so
we have molecular biology data, clinically
significant conditions generally
hypopigmentation, different types of
albinism, non-human animals especially the
mouse has really been influential in
helping us understand how genes affect
pigmentation. We can follow evolution in a
number of ways; molecular evolution as
well as just the evolution across
different populations. And finally,
Admixture mapping. This is an approach to
find the genes that determine differences
between populations. When we have those
genes, we can then use them to design more
experiments to help us understand better
how they function. So knowing those genes
is really central. We can address
questions like where and when these new
gene mutations happen that give us
different skin color in this case,
potentially improved diagnostic and
treatments, test different kinds of
molecular hypotheses and finally predict
trait values. This could be useful in a
forensic context when the person's not
there, you don't have any information
about who he is, to make some predictions
as well as in Epidemiology. Skin is
mediating something about the disease
condition. We know it's really critical in
producing enough Vitamin D.
We can measure the skin from the DNA
alone, so not having measured it in the
person. So there's a lot of potential
there. Here's an example of a melanocyte
and keratinocytes, typically they reach up
to 30 or 40 keratinocytes and pass off
melanosomes. So it's just a little bit
about the biology. We know a lot about the
genes that are forming these melanosomes
and controlling their transfer up to the
keratinocytes. I've always been fascinated
by human variation and here's a slide of
18 young women who we collected recently
as part of our sampling. You can get
quickly a sense of the diversity of human
pigmentation; skin, hair, and eyes from
this. We can look at more detailed
descriptions, quantitative descriptions.
This is a histogram showing the
pigmentation levels measured in three
populations. The one on the far left is
European-American sample from State
College, the black bars to the right are
African-Americans from Washington DC, and
then a sample of African-Caribbeans from
England. The African-Caribbeans are
shifted over to the right a little bit
compared to the African-Americans and
that's darker skin. In fact they have less
European ancestry, less European admixture
than the African-Americans do; about 10%
compared to 20%. So there's a strong
relationship there between your recent
admixture and your skin color. We do see
too, this red bar here shows the extent of
overlap because this slide also emphasizes
how our observation of each other is
substantially biased.
Sociologists have studied this in detail
and light skinned people see dark skin
people as darker than they are. Dark
skinned people see light skinned people as
lighter than they are. So you can't really
rely on your perceptions or at least it's
worth looking inward to see what effect
that may have on how you see those around
you. We know the environment has been a
major factor in the evolution of skin
color. That green line there is the
equator and latitude or the distance north
and south of the equator have a major
effect on skin color. We know from more
detailed analyses that it's actually the
ultraviolet radiation at ground level that
really has the strongest effect on skin
color. So our skin is tied to the
environment and we can propose or discuss
the different mechanisms that may be
controlling this response. I think the
strongest evidence is for lightning of
skin due to the need to produce Vitamin D.
A very few natural sources that we can
dietarily consume enough Vitamin D to keep
us healthy, but our skin can produce
Vitamin D. So with ultraviolet light
hitting your skin, you can produce Vitamin
D if your skin's light enough for that
environment and if you're exposed enough,
if you have enough skin showing and if you
spend enough time outdoors. So lots of
conditions on being healthy through
getting your Vitamin D from your skin.
Potentially immune suppression is also
something that is good in certain
instances. Darker skin probably evolved to
protect us from sunburn, skin cancer,
protect us from too much immune
suppression and also perhaps to mediate
folic acid photolysis to protect our folic
acid stores from being destroyed.
Ultraviolet light helps to create Vitamin
D, but it also destroys folic acid.
Finally, both low and high pigmentation
can be mediated through sexual selection
and also the relaxation of selection as
population move from one area to another
area. We can talk about the average
history of individuals, persons and
populations. And this tree shows... I know
it's kind of complex but that's really the
best representation that we can make of
our history. Although this is about 10
years old, I think it still holds in most
of the major branches here. And it's not
only a branching through the fission,
separation of populations, but also the
fusion of populations. You can see here
how we have drawn these little branches
here to illustrate admixture or the
movement of people to join other
populations. Our species really has much
more of a wisteria vine history when
branches cross they fuse and they join
again making new populations as opposed to
any kind of tree or bush pattern. That is
an average pattern. Evolution really
doesn't happen...at least a lot of
evolution, the adaptive evolution, happens
more on a gene by gene basis. So it's
modular, each gene has its own history.
The genes that cause differences among us
today are genes that have very recent
evolutionary histories and have been very
actively evolving in the past 75,000
years, say, since human population had
their common origin in Africa. Many
populations stayed in Africa, some small
set of populations moved out of Africa.
We have tools that let us study how
these...tracking the molecular evolution
of these genes and how quickly they
evolved showing clear evidence that they
have evolved recently or changed frequency
recently. So these are very valuable
tools. I'll show you an application of one
of those methods in a minute. But I want
to focus really on just three populations
to start with. These aren't the three most
important populations or three central
populations. That tree I showed you before
is really a better sampling of human
diversity, but these are worth looking at.
We were initially very light skinned
before we lost our fur, all mammals are.
You spread your cat's fur, even if it's a
black cat, you'll see the skin is white
underneath. As we lost our fur, changed
our habits, we needed to become dark
skinned. There's other branches here, the
second branch is a common branch to East
Asians and Europeans. The third branch
there would contain skin lightening events
that were specific to East Asians, the
fourth branch is the branch specific to
European changes. Finally, additional skin
darkening events possibly on that fifth
branch that I show in this tree. So I
mentioned admixture mapping before and
this is really a fundamental tool for
finding genes that cause differences
between populations. Most of the genes are
the same across all populations. If you
look at the frequencies of alleles across
populations, about 95% of the total
variation is in common. We have this very
recent common history, but for certain
things, especially superficial aspects,
superficial traits, we have evolved very
quickly and we can map those kinds of
genes with this approach. So we basically
start out with two parents; one light skin
and one dark skin. These are the
histograms describing their distributions.
When they mate, you have the first admixed
generation and there is much less
variation in skin color here or whatever
trait it is that you're talking about.
Everybody has two copies, two genomes; one
from European ancestor and one from an
African ancestor in this case. But by the
second generation and all the generations
afterwards, you have a lot of variation. A
lot of phenotypic variation and these are
ideal samples for discovering which are
the genes that are affecting this trait.
Here it is as a chromosomal view. So you
have two European chromosomes, two African
chromosomes or one of each. You get one of
each by having one parent from each
population. These black bars are
recombination points so you don't pass on
to your kids the same chromosomes you got
from your parents. You mix them up and
then pass on this mixed up set of
chromosomes to your kids. And after a few
generations, you end up with these
chimeric chromosomes that have different
ancestry segments. We can track those
ancestry segments and use that information
to map genes. We do need to be careful
about stratification. So there's variation
in admixture levels across population.
This slide here shows you how the
proportion of West African ancestry is
positively correlated with the skin color
measure, the M index. You see a positive
correlation, you also see the variance is
different so there is a lot more
dispersion here, a lot more variability.
This is because like most traits, skin
color is much more variable in Africa.
Even just considering the subset of
Africa, West Africa where the enslaved
ancestors of the African-Americans and
Brazilians and other populations that are
represented here were derived. So even at
that subset of Africa is much more
variable than Europe.
But you have this confounding. So you have
to deal with the fact that ancestry is
going to be correlated with any...our skin
color will be correlated with any marker
that you measure that's different between
those parental groups. But you can reduce
that, you can remove that statistically.
It's a process called conditioning or
controlling. You basically remove the
effects of one variable to study another.
This is the Duffy null locus, locus of
very substantially between populations and
you can see the genotype determines the
distribution of skin color. It has nothing
to do with skin color. When you control
for the variation and ancestry, you get
rid of that effect on skin color. This is
the cover of the journal where we
published on the SLC24A5 gene. This gene
was first discovered by Keith Cheng as the
golden gene for zebra fish. So it affected
zebra fish coloration. Keith called me up
and said, "Hey, maybe this affects skin
color." I was quite skeptical until I
looked at public data set where it showed
a locus where Europeans, the blue dot
here, were totally fixed for an allele.
You didn't find much in other populations.
That's a very unusual circumstance and
sure enough it has a very dramatic effect
on skin color. You can see that here even
after controlling for ancestry, you still
have a strong effect on skin color. And in
fact in genome-wide admixture mapping we
find SLC24A5 is really the strongest gene
affecting skin color. You see these other
smaller peaks here. Once you condition for
the effect of SLC24A5, those genes are
much more prominent. So you can see that
you can detect those. So this statistical
conditioning is a very common tool and
very useful.
One of the interesting things we found
about not only SLC24A5 but some of those
other genes that come up in this gene
mapping analysis like SLC45A2 or the MATP
gene is that the variation that causes
Europeans to be light skinned is not the
same as the variation that causes East
Asians to be light skinned. So this
selective pressure to lighten the skin
probably in response to migrating to
higher latitudes where there's less UV
light was quite strong. I mean it seems to
affect any population that moves to a
higher latitude. This is really kind of
unexpected. We had other hypotheses about
populations like Melanesians maybe they
shared or didn't share genes with darker
skinned populations, but this is what we
found. And in fact, there are many genes,
I'm not going to talk to you about many of
these other genes, but I just wanted to
show you a slide that identified what
we're finding about where these genes
occur and on which branches they seem to
have evolved. So we're not finding too
many that are on this common branch of
lightning, in the common population coming
out of Africa and only a few that are back
as far as on the common branch of all
human populations. But some of these are
more difficult to study, too. This is
probably the case. I don't think that
those genes don't exist and we can't
understand them, we just haven't been able
to find them yet. One very interesting
tool we have is to look at the local
genetic diversity. So this is using Short
Tandem Repeats or STRs. If you watch too
many crime TV shows, you probably already
know this acronym.
But these are the markers you use for
identity analysis if you have a forensic
case you type the STR alleles. You can see
there's lots of different variants. This
is the chromosome here that doesn't have
the new allele, the A allele, that gives
you a lighter skin. This is the chromosome
with the lighter skin. So you can see
there is much less variation on that
chromosome even though it's basically
fixed in Europeans. So there's lots of
copies of that chromosome which usually
means it's old and you are going to see
lots of different mutations on it. Lots of
different STR alleles, but you don't. You
only see pretty much one primary alleles
on most of these. So you can use that
information to date when that mutation
occurred or when it started to change
frequency. That's really the more
important point is when did that really
start to evolve. So the dates or the time
is here and the selective coefficient, how
strong the selection was is there, and you
can put these on a tree then. So you can
look at when the timing of some of these
genes SLC24A5, MATP, and TRP1 changed
frequency compared to when KIT Ligand and
some of the other ones changed frequency.
And they seem to match those splits on the
tree. So I just want to say we're very
grateful to all of our volunteers who
participated in these research projects
and I have lots of other colleagues who
have also helped in getting to this point
and then several other research labs as
well who are looking into a lot of these
same questions. Thank you very much.
♪ [music] ♪